of course for many many years countless
years I would start my show with a
couple of jokes upfront I haven't been
doing those and some people think I
haven't been doing them because we don't
have a studio audience well maybe that's
part of the reason but mostly I haven't
been doing jokes because I'm so used to
having my pal Andy there and just
hearing him chuckle and react to the
different jokes is such a such a fun
part of my day that hasn't been the same
so I wanted Andy tonight to be present
when I told a couple of monologue jokes
but unfortunately his internet is down
he's got bad Wi-Fi his internet has been
down all day so I asked aunty to
pre-record some reactions and we would
drop them into a little monologue right
now and you won't even notice the
difference so these are pre-recorded
Andy reactions that will go with my
monologue tonight and let's get right
into that monologue shall we I have it
right here on my phone courtesy of the
writers ah here we go well of course
it's been about a month since
everybody's been indoors getting paler
and whiter so welcome to my world
yeah all right Andy
yeah what else is going on president
Trump here this president Trump decided
to add his signature to all of these
stimulus checks yeah he added his
signature to all the stimulus checks
yeah so uh ninety percent chance those
checks will bounce boy you can say that
again thanks pal great job all right
Governor Cuomo wants all New York
citizens to wear masks now yeah yeah
everyone has to wear masks are the the
players on the New York Jets said that's
okay we're used to hiding our identity I
guess he'd like to buy a vowel yeah okay
anyway yeah quarantine is tough
authorities in Indonesia hired people to
dress as ghosts to scare Indonesians
back into their homes yeah the the
population of Indonesia apparently is 80
percent toddler oh that was beautifully
said thank you for that
okay and of course just on a slightly
personal note a little bit of a sad time
for me this this period in April because
this is the 25th anniversary of the
passing of my grandfather Sean so I
think of him during this time and still
feel that sense of loss okay yeah great
Andy okay I would marry Huey gluey and
kill Dewey